tu as lu votre table est prête à superbe
amos est vraiment 40 cm c'est ça du tout
non monsieur je vous invite à vivre un
truc extraordinaire
à soupe et d'un avion des quotas on va
chez fernand dit on va chez fernand tu y
vas avec une amie
cb
alexandre je suis là super soirée
paris rencontrer car j'en fais comme tu
l'as où tu es comme toutes les petites
filles j'ai rêvé du prince charmant qui
seraient grands qui serait fort qui me
portait dans ses bras et son château
je veux continuer va continuer quoi à
croire à cette histoire
ok qu'est ce que tu viens de dire je dis
ok blanche neige je t'interdis de ma
fait comme ça notre histoire est
terminée elle était avec moi maintenant
alors qu'il passe à autre chose ou pas
tu me l'as douanes a fait son choix et
c'est pas toi c'est quoi jacques
massacré connard
tu me
ah ah
quand
le climat où il fait vraiment d'accord
oui je connais la gamme aux insurgés
esthétique
j'aurais fait